okay well i obviously have to lead with  your name is prince herb now like i  can't call it let's use your other name  so  where when did that change yeah so i  lost on the show and i got punished and  this is my new identity now um so  it's a whole thing they made me pierce  my ears and wear diamond studs  and my name is prince they're changing  my name in the credits and the intros on  all my press  print everything in my life when i do  stand-up comedy i get called to the  stage as prince herb now  and i have to do this till the end of  this season it's terrible it's really  funny when you're not you man  yep i'm still here just waiting for you  to subscribe  if you don't i'll be trapped in this box  forever help